ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show i
feel i have a hundred and four fever
i have a dry cough i have shortness of
breath i have blood clotting
and i refuse to get tested and i refuse
to change my behavior
and i don't know if i have coven but i
have a dry cough
and i have blood clots and i have
tightness of chest and shortness of
breath and i have 104
fever and i have blue toes
and i'm speaking perfect mandarin
which is amazing i wake up every day i
speak
perfect mandarin i don't know what i
have
the jury is out no i'm kidding i do feel
horrible though
because ray has been here for a week and
uh
i mean this has been i've this this week
i've been
so i've treated myself worse this week
it is ballsy in a pandemic people don't
realize what balls is anymore in this
country
it's ballsy during a pandemic to eat ice
cream cake
and smoke a pack of cigarettes every day
it's ballsy
there is no er like or
whatever the icu i don't even know what
these
but no one there's no capacity if you
show up to a hospital in california now
they just smack you across the face
and every day i'm eating
ice cream cake and cigarettes because
raymond is here and i mean it's just a
celebration
you know he drinks what is that a liter
what is that a two liter of the diet
sodas
like three times cokes yeah yeah well
and he loves the ciggies loves them and
it's hard it's hard
i got we went to coldstone and got two
ice cream cakes for new year's
after the new year's uh thing we did a
lot of fun thanks to tina 40.
alex was dark it was dark
some people commented it was a little
dark you know
he said the a jellyfish in it i don't
know
people are going to get mad you should
have pushed back
you didn't debate him yeah man i don't
know
i don't know how to have that argument
imagine you were sitting there and a guy
turns around and goes that vaccine's got
jellyfish in it
really the only thing you can say is
[ __ ] really
is that is that okay
and then he started talking about the
lazarus gene and a woman who cells
kept replicating henrietta lacks
a black woman who's was eaten by the
blob
he was saying yeah well yeah cells
turned into like
her cells are still alive yeah but this
had something to do with fouchy
yeah i was confused
but i don't know anymore i just don't
know i just know that i got gotta really
stop eating ice cream cake and smoking
butts every day
i mean just i burnt my mouth
my mouth feels horrible my skin feels
like it's cracking off my face
i mean it's just bad
i i just feel so unhealthy and that's
why i'm making a change
this year i'm making a very big change
and i'm switching to ultra lights
i'm going to do a pack of no i'm kidding
my friend's father used to smoke those
marlboro ultralights it was like air
yeah what's the point you know
they're like basics yeah i just feel
like
garbage and i mean do they still make
them still make the ultralight i don't
think so no
yeah it's an old school pack i'm getting
a personal trainer in here i mean my
personal trainer got covered
that's his level of commitment he's that
guy got coveted
i hired a trainer he got coveted
so this is where we're at my personal
trainer is sick
what am i supposed to do except go to
cold stone and get two ice cream cakes
and a pack of marlboro lights
and eat ice cream cake and marlboro
lights in the back and that's
real ball that's badass [ __ ]
people think bad ass [ __ ] is throwing
parties
i'm i'm taking as many chances as any of
these tick tockers throwing a big
orgy i'm sitting in my backyard
smoking cigarettes with my morbidly
obese friend
who's what is he four five four or
something yeah yeah
i mean what are you gonna do it's it's
you're you're really
taking a risk with your life and i can't
live like that i feel
horrible you feel really bad
when you eat like the worst food
ever you feel bad i just feel bad my
throat my nose i just everything about
me you you
felt kind of bad the other night yeah i
felt bad this yesterday morning again
i mean you just feel like [ __ ] you want
to do yoga i mean i'm living in l.a i
should be doing yoga
i should be in the sun i should be
outside not to smoke
to [ __ ] you know i should be spray
painting nancy pelosi's garage
what did they say on her garage cancel
rent
pull it up no one's canceling rent i
mean
you know listen all these things would
be nice but
2k cancel rent we want everything
with a pig and some blood
well it's nice that these people calm
down after uh trump lost huh
that was what i thought would happen by
the way hey egg on my face
but i get it cause this you know these
people have done nothing for anybody so
if this is real and this happened and
it's not
nancy pelosi out there doing it with her
husband
um she paid some neighborhood kid to
come over and do this
she's like we're getting we're getting a
little heat let's just let's put some
lamb's blood on the door here
so we can get some sympathy points from
people
but i mean i get the rage and the anger
at this woman
i you know i'm not a fan but uh
cancel rent we want everything
i mean well what do you think you're
gonna get
i mean i don't even know anymore about
the two thousand dollar checks
are they coming who's getting them don't
know yet is hilaria baldwin getting two
grand
i hope she does who cares that she wants
to be a hispanic
it makes you interesting it's nice when
someone puts on an accent
i like that being who you are is stupid
truly be another thing
if you're not interesting make yourself
interesting
and she's like she wanted to be like
penelope cruz or
catherine zeta jones or one of them
catherine zeta jones spanish uh let me
see
well whatever it doesn't matter let's
not lose our [ __ ] minds here
the point is that she wanted to be a
spanish lady
so what she wanted to be a high-class
immigrant let her let her be it
stop getting mad at her i'm i defend her
i defend her right to envision a
different life
for herself than the one she had she
married the psychopath millionaire
and and she goes it's not good enough
because i go to parties and everyone
goes oh you're just this guy's [ __ ]
i want to be something interesting and
you know those white [ __ ] love as
someone is slightly different
white people love when someone is
slightly different which is what she
is it's slightly different it's not that
different
she's not in ms13 she's not in la raza
and i'm not equating those two things
i'm just saying she's not selling uh
you know uh mango with paprika in soho
she's slightly different ever so
slightly she's different
she's a few degrees away from a basic
white [ __ ]
let her be it she's not sister soldier
she's just different enough to make
upper class white people
it's a little spice it's a little spice
i don't see the problem with it she's
not
going all the way here she's just doing
that coma said he said cucumber
i don't know how you say cook up though
it's cute
it's kind of cute it's endearing
it's cute it makes me like her more the
commitment
to that is is impressive to me i'm
impressed
by her that she goes i just want to be a
little she's clearly not hispanic
at all in any meaningful way
but she just wants to be a little bit
people don't realize how hard it is to
be rich
that's the problem too many people are
focused on like
oh i don't have health insurance my
mom's dead
there's no appreciation for the
struggles of the wealthy in this country
none it's true you know
it it's too much focus
on people without and not enough about
people
with hilaria baldwin
is thrust into this world of very
interesting capable intelligent people
and she's got no way to differentiate
herself she's a basic white [ __ ]
she's a live laugh love chardonnay [ __ ]
and she just [ __ ] lucked out
with that alec baldwin who's you know
always you know telling his daughter
she's a pig and
punching photographers and doing a
horrible trump impression by the way
on that horrible show on saturday night
you should watch this
and she meets these people and they're
endlessly fascinating and they've had
distinguished careers in the arts and
politics or whatever
and she just wants to be a smidgen
different just a little different
than a regular white [ __ ] she just
wants to be a little
cool and have people ask her what was it
like in spain what was that
like you're different from we are did
you sit and paint little tiles and make
tapas
did you eat jamon that's what she wants
she wants people to ask her
and she would tell stories probably fake
little stories and me and my grandmother
i'd not speak to her and we go to the
village and we make
we take the pig and we carve the pig
into the jamon
that's all she wants to do i'm in full
support of her
would it heal the country if the cops
shot her imma do the aisle i'ma do
diallo style
like 41 times against saks fifth avenue
perhaps
if the cops just shot her 41 times as
she drops her bags at bergdorf goodman
and just empty
emptied into her i mean would people be
happy with that
perhaps but i don't know we don't have
to keep shaming this woman for wanting
to be slightly different
what's the problem i like it go right
back to it i hope she's asian next
how interesting it would be what if one
of your friends just became asian you
wouldn't respect them more
if i had a friend that became asian i
would respect them
so much more than i currently do just
found a way to like
be asian like start looking asian
dressing asian
creating an entire identity as an asian
person saying they
grew up in asia saying they grew up in
japan when it was just
provably untrue that would be your
coolest friend
because you'd be like this person's
asian now i knew her when she was an
asian and that's where we're gonna add
i mean somebody tweeted on twitter the
other day gender is not a big deal
that's why nobody cares about
transgender why we all have to be the
race we're born
let people switch yeah yeah that makes
sense let people be fluid baby let
people be flee you want to be black and
be black
you want to you know there's you know
that's a mixed bag
according to black people they'll tell
you it's not all nice
uh but let people be asian
i would like to be another race why why
do i have to be an irish
prick for my entire life this red face
irish ranting goblin for my entire
goddamn life
why can't i be castilian spanish like
i'm nice white spanish
or why can't i be asian why can't i be
russian i don't understand that and i
think it's a
stupid kind of [ __ ]
outdated thing so i applaud her
and and whatever she wants to do i
support her i think that [ __ ] people get
angry about this [ __ ]
for no goddamn reason i mean
she's just a little different she's not
she's not like walking around trying to
be a maid she's not trying to be a lower
class
person she's trying to be upper she's
still she's not
she's not stabbing her class in the back
here she's still going to garden parties
and drinking [ __ ] viv
click o she just does it with a little
accent it would be really
uh gross if she like was pretending to
be a maid or something right
because we'd all be like you don't have
to do this [ __ ] it would be really bad
if she was pretending
to do something like that but she's just
putting on a little accent kind of the
way madonna did
it's really not that big of a deal
speaking of maids my maid
is as fat and as lazy as i am what's the
point of having her
she come the other day and i can't she's
in here no mask i don't know where she's
been
she's in here the other day in my
kitchen and we're both silently eating a
pumpkin loaf
not no one's cleaning if i want i'm fat
and lazy i don't need another fat and
lazy person
to just stare at me you know i mean i
don't know what to do with this woman i
like her and i tip her and i give her a
lot of money
but she's slow and she just doesn't do
much
she talks on the phone she's on a phone
it's literally me
i'm bringing in another me to my house
she's on the phone all the time
it takes her forever to go through go
through the house
i'm just i'm importing another version
of myself here
but that's not what hilaria is doing
hilarious not cause people ask me to
talk about this they're like
what's your take on it i'm like i think
rich people should be able to pretend to
be
other races i believe that
sorry maybe that's not a popular take
but i believe it's
fun and they should be allowed to do it
and i think many people are going to
disagree with me because they're like
but she's not pretending to be like a
poor oppressed per if she was doing
blackface and had dreads
i get it it would be a little offensive
it would be offensive if she was in full
black face with like a bob marley wig
and she's like hey man what's a dual mod
like i understand that okay
but she's not doing any of that she's
just pretending to be an upper-class
hispanic person
which is just a few degrees to the left
of what she is which is just a basic
white [ __ ]
there's nothing wrong with that i i am
for
the ability of rich people and poor
people if they can pull it off
it's like mark norman has a joke about
transgender people it's like you know
caitlyn jenner can do anything she wants
she's got the money so like if you're
poor and you could pull off being
another race good for you
but rich people should be able
to to try on another uh
country's history if they so choose
i don't see a problem with it i don't
see any problem it doesn't bother me at
all
i would love someone if in the middle of
a thick russian accent they whispered to
me goes
listen i decided to be russian three
years ago i'm not russian i decided to
be russian three years ago and i came up
with this whole backstory and it's it's
just fun
life is too short to enforce these rigid
roles on people it's crazy many of you
are offended by it because it's you why
don't you cook up something good
you figure out how to do something you
know
what else is going on i just wanted to
address that because i feel like people
are
being unnecessarily harsh
immigrants are heading back to mexico
now yeah
see this is what i mean if i saw hilaria
baldwin
with a bunch of coyotes in a van heading
back to the border going it didn't work
i would say this is a bit much but she's
not doing that years of anti-immigrant
policies from the trump administration
have been
magnified by insecurities resulting from
the pandemic yeah i think it was more
the pandemic
yeah people are going back they're
saying let's go back to mexico which is
a narco state on our southern border for
good reason it supplies us all this blow
by the way
there's no reason to have just a narco
state on our southern border if we
weren't propping that up
and getting everything we want from it
it's our personal pharmacy
sitting below america and i'm sure
somebody else has said that but it's
absolutely true
that's why we have a narco state there
so people can go and get there
go down a [ __ ] tulum and have a nice
weekend
that's exactly what this is so they're
going back there
and um you know it's unfortunate but uh
or
i don't know i don't know it's it's all
about uh
i don't care anymore this is the problem
with the news is i i can't care anymore
about any event it's like
there's nothing going on to even care
about anymore go
come i don't know there was this that
was interesting
national police defend response to the
yeah
why because everyone's going to say the
national bomber was white
yeah and they knocked on his door twice
and they gave up yeah yeah
listen everybody everybody in this car
here's why
i'm not saying the police aren't racist
but here's the problem with this
everybody in this country
is is is three to four days away from
detonating a bomb somewhere
that's every person if the cops went to
every that's every commenter on my
youtube
every person in america is three to four
days away from just getting a [ __ ]
gun
and going hog wild somewhere it's just
we're on the edge everybody's on the
brink so they can't waste their time
with every tip for every crazy dude
who's
[ __ ] on the brink i'm three to four
days away i'm doing okay i'm doing well
and i'm three to four days away from
building a bomb and detonating outside
of
billy eilish's house so what are you
going to do you're going to check me out
on that and i'll probably get up on that
fourth day and decide not to do it
because i've had a mcgriddle or
something i don't know but most people
are in lured fantasies of murder people
in this country are only kept alive
by two fantasies one getting really rich
and two burning it all down those are
the only things people go to bed at
night
thinking about murdering everyone they
know and
having a [ __ ] lamborghini those are
the two things in america
that unite us as a culture literally the
only two
that's the problem it's like they tried
to enforce that thing with kids
uh school shooters kids make lists of
people they're gonna kill and they're
like
we should but yeah but you should be
allowed you should be allowed to sit
there in the back of your marble
notebook and
you know i'd really like to blow their
heads off
steve you know sharon paul
you're allowed until you do it until you
load the gun and go in there and do it
this preventative [ __ ] gets a little
creepy because most people are just
fantasizing all the time about killing
everyone that they know
that's absolutely true and if you're not
well god bless you but you're missing
out on the whole experience of america
the whole experience of america is
thinking about getting away with the
murder of your spouse
going nuts in your office and blowing
everyone's brains out
or finding a way to [ __ ] invest
successfully in a time
share that's it there's really nothing
left to do
psychologically in this country we are
so drugged up on cheap food and booze
and pills
we can barely see straight we have no
idea what's going on we have no health
care
we have no insurance there's no
education people are [ __ ]
stagnant wages have stagnated for
[ __ ] decades
and the you know people have just jerked
all the come out of their dicks they're
on too many [ __ ] pills to even come
they're just
coming air they can barely feel the
sensation of the tip of their penis
women have to shove [ __ ] hot pokers
in their vagina to get an orgasm
the only thing we have left is to
fantasize about the murder and
destruction
of our communities let us have it
you can't respond to everybody who talks
a little wildly at a bar about settling
scores
because every day you just yeah
did you say you were going to show
everyone at your office that you're a
real [ __ ] man
and you were going to end this once and
for all i quote
you're going to get respect one way or
the other i
quote and you're not going to be happy i
quote and when you see what i'll do to
you you
won't be happy you better run run i'll
get like it's just
every day so many
fantasies of of murdering people
and you can't no obviously maybe they
should have done
more it clearly seems like it now
i mean hindsight is always 20 20 right
it's 20 20. but the fantasy life that we
all have has been magnified by the
internet it's been magnified by our
ability
to tell other people about these
fantasies and have them go that's a good
idea
and and it just because but that's why
you need comedy and that's why you need
freedom of speech that's why you need
all of these spaces for people to
release tension and say all this [ __ ]
and get it out
so that they don't do it because a
percentage of them are going to do it
but it's important for people to let to
have these fantasies
you know what i mean it's important
probably porn even the porn has so many
negative effects it's important to have
a little porn so people don't you know
put their wife's head in the bag
so they go let me wat let me get off to
something
instead of making my wife do it i
shouldn't choke my wife till she turns
blue
but if i watch somebody get choked till
they turn blue maybe i get it out of my
system
that's porn it's a fantasy life it's not
real
sex doesn't feel like porn ever really
unless you're
amazing at it in great shape sex is
different
than the depiction of sex as is murder
i've never
murdered anyone but it looks amazing
watching the life
leave someone's eyes looks great it
looks amazing you and a buddy you and
your best bud go and just [ __ ] murder
someone you know
just [ __ ] blood everywhere and just
[ __ ] stabbing someone
but in real life that activity is
probably
different it feels different right but
you should be able to fantasize about it
you need you need these things so it's
hard to live in a free country where the
cops are always supposed to
respond to every [ __ ] utterance of a
person who's on a brink you know
how many people said they were going to
spray paint nancy pelosi's garage and
leave a pig head on it
many probably many but only one person
did it and her name is nancy pelosi
you see many people wanted to do that
but nancy pelosi finally did it
do you see how that works so that
somebody could be sympathetic and go
yeah
yeah they're stealing all our money and
they've destroyed the country
hollowed out many of our important
institutions
but you can't leave a pig head on the
[ __ ] dude
you left a pig head in the driveway it's
too much
i mean listen i get it i never advocate
violence i never advocate anything but i
understand why things happen
i don't have to advocate violence but i
understand what happens when you make
people desperate and scared they respond
like
you ever corner an animal you have a
corner of someone without realizing you
you're trying to get you're trying to
approach a dog the wrong way and it bark
and it bites you
this is what's happening with the
american public you're you're forcing
them into a corner and they're
scratching and clawing and they're going
to come out and bite you i don't know
who did that to pelosi's house
i have a good idea maybe i don't know
you know
it's probably oscar
would be funny if they arrested oscar
cat for that
san francisco he could have got up there
yeah absolutely could have he's a real
problem
or a solution but
i just got to stop eating ice cream cake
and i've still got it left we went to
coldstone which is not as good as carvel
but it's still a decent ice cream cake
it is good it's it's a fine ice cream
cake it's got the cake and the ice cream
layers of the cake and then the ice
cream you see
and after a cold stone ice cream you
wake up and i want to kill
everybody because i didn't have that
discipline to not eat it
it's the lack of discipline that builds
the rage it's the lack of discipline
that makes you angry you're really angry
at yourself
but there's so much to be angry about in
this country justifiably
and sometimes you need to blow off a
little steam you gotta go you know i'm
gonna bun you know what i'm gonna bomb
you're sitting there with a friend you
go you know you know what i'm gonna bomb
you know hey buddy you know what i'm
gonna bomb you know what i'm sicker
i'm just gonna [ __ ] i'm gonna i'm
gonna bomb
i'm gonna bomb uh where did he even bomb
nashville
what are you even doing what's he even
doing he put a van in nashville who
cares
who's he bombing there miranda lambert
some country singer what's he doing
i don't even understand what kind of
shitty half-measure is that
how many people did even kill no and
just a couple dogs that were in the van
yeah what even was this he did it on
christmas morning and he played a
warning to let everyone know to get out
of the area and then it exploded is this
some sloppy false flag at langley
they're like okay this didn't work next
time we got to take out more than a few
dogs
guys this is a real embarrassment are
you nuts we took out a few dogs
that's not going to get him to take this
vaccine you killed a couple of [ __ ]
golden retrievers
in the middle of nashville we need them
to take this goddamn vaccine they got to
be scared
this was supposed to be a guy who kova
drove to terrorism that'll be the next
thing he'll go
covet is now driving people to terrorism
that'll be one of the symptoms of culver
by the way blowing up the van in
nashville
do you have shortness of breath of fever
symptoms of the flu have you thought
about blowing up a van in downtown
nashville
you might have the novel coronavirus
whose symptoms now include any type of
anti-government behavior
if you don't want to turn into a
terrorist get the needle
now we're going to need people to get
this vaccine i mean i don't need to get
it right away i want
some other people to get it first you
know the majority of the country and
then i will i'll get in on the last
round that but by the way
that's how respectful i am of the heroes
yes do you understand that of course
because i believe that the
first responders heroes nurses teachers
all them give give it to them
and i'll get it later
i'll get it later i here's what i will
this is the pledge i'll make because i
care so much
about this country i will take it last
i will take it last after 350 million
people have gotten it
uh i will take it last
as coveted vaccines come online fewer
americans want to take them here's one
of the problems it's not one coveted
vaccine it's like
there's now multiple ones there's like i
got the pfizer i got the moderna nobody
knows what end is up there's no
authority in the government nobody
trusts any of this [ __ ] and i'm not an
anti-vaxxer but this vaccine is pretty
quick
yeah right it's too fast
it's too fast
asians will all do it when asked
recently eighty percent of asians will
get killed
yeah well they're gangsters they're
taking over the world they're like this
is how we're gonna do it
i think women are the lowest well many
of them are having babies right they
want to get pregnant they don't want to
affect their children i get it
you get it yeah now
now this is crazy when you and your wife
came over christmas
she had a needle of the vaccine for me
that was my gift
which i didn't take but it was odd that
she came over where did you get that
she got it from work
no i'm kidding ben ben and his wife got
me a candle
for christmas which is very nice what's
some other stuff well it's from target
no the the candles actually whitney
would be impressed with that candle
that's a candle from nordstrom that's a
it's a nice uh i mean whitney's probably
in a youth hostel
she'd be impressed by solid food i
haven't heard from her in two weeks
what colors are here now i i have no
idea what she's doing
i mean whitney's impressed if she gets
you know if she gets an hour of sunlight
they let her out
of course this is a joke but is it i
don't know i haven't heard from her two
weeks i showed her her house at
christmas to give her a present she like
wouldn't let me in
yeah i have no idea what's going on i
have no idea what's going on
i mean maybe someone will hear this and
get to her i mean i hope she's okay
i mean i don't know is she driving
around nashville in the van
i don't know what's going on i just know
around the third hair color change
people started to go uh where's this
going
where does this end have you ever known
someone who's dyed their hair four times
and it ends in a good place
i'm just asking have you ever met
somebody who's had four hair color
changes
and then the fifth change is like back
to normal and they're like hey guys
welcome good to see you things are good
you know i don't know what's going on
she doesn't call me anymore it's okay
i don't need friends either
unnecessary unnecessary
you know especially ones in the midst of
a timothy mcveigh style
breakdown by the way you wanna the cops
want to follow up go to her house
who the hell knows what she's gonna do
she's like gonna she'll find a way to
bomb the virtual emmys or something i
don't know
she'll bomb jimmy kimmel's house
it's a comedy podcast everyone
the comedy show we're all having fun
and there's nothing but love here for
everyone i just got her a present she
didn't answer the [ __ ] door i thought
it was a little rude
where'd you get her what where'd you get
her i didn't really get her anything
i just wanted to say hello i was bored
yeah
what am i gonna get her another horse
she's fine um
i'll tell you this though i um no i like
that you and your wife got a candle for
me where
where was from where nordstrom oh nice
good
yeah how much it was expensive how much
i'll ask katie but i think it was in the
room of like eighty dollars eighty
dollars
yeah an eighty dollar candle but that
was not a christmas present that was a
housewarming gift the other gift was the
which was the
how much the crew set how much i think
all in all william sonoma i spent like
480 on the crusade well i got the crew
set and then the nice big cutting board
which was nice
for who for you okay so 500
williamsonnoma i think about around 500
okay that's not horrible not bad that's
pretty nice
and then the candle oh and we got you
flowers too the little flowers from a
floral shop
well what a treat
and the vaccine and she gave me a needle
and said a nice needle and she said
inject this
later tonight so and she handed me a
paper sign which
signed she said it was a power of
attorney that you and her would have
power of attorney over all my
financial decisions i thought that was
odd
i love cereal magicspoon.com tim dillon
that's what you gotta do you gotta grab
a variety pack of cereal and try today
zero sugar 11 grams of protein it has
three net grams of carbs in each serving
so many have asked and now you can
finally build your very own custom
variety box
you can choose from the best-selling
cocoa fruity frosted and blueberry plus
brand new flavors including peanut
butter and cinnamon
i really love the fruity flavor it
tastes exactly like fruit loops it's
exactly like
the fruit loops that you grew up with as
a kid this is for people
that really want to have something sweet
but not have any of the the carbs or the
sugar okay i'm telling you right now
this is a great thing if you're on if
it's a keto friendly if you're on a diet
that requires you to severely limit your
carbs and sugar this is a way to replace
a meal you can have it if you work in an
office which nobody does now but
eventually people are going to again
it's easy to bring with you you can use
it it's an easy meal replacement it's a
great breakfast replacement especially
if you're on a ketogenic or a diet like
that you get up you have a bowl of magic
spoon you go on about your day
whatever a little high protein greek
yogurt you know then then you do the
meats and the cheeses and the things
like that later on in the day but this
is a great way to do it
or if you love dessert and you like
something sweet after you have a keto
or you know whatever low carb meal you
can add a little magic spoon and it's
sweet
is it sweet and it's a little pricey and
the reason it's pricey is because it's
sweetened with
you know monk fruit extract and all
these things that are actually natural
sweeteners
they're not sugar you know they're
absolutely not sugar and that's so
that's the difference it's keto friendly
gluten-free grain-free soy-free
carb gmo free okay
this is the type of thing that a lot of
people
are getting into right now they're
getting into it because
it is the new year and it is time for a
new them a lot of you are sitting out
there and you're sick of being a fat
slug and you don't know how to change
your life okay
you're a fat slug and you disgust
yourself the odors that emanate
from your body sicken you you're rotting
away a literal corpse
sitting there like a bloated body they
found in the river that kids poke a
stick out
and you're sick of that you're sick of
taking pictures of yourself from
different angles and putting on dating
apps you're taking photos from up there
and people see the top of your head who
are you [ __ ] kidding
you're sick of facetiming people like
this holding your phone so high your
[ __ ] arm is [ __ ] sore
because you keep taking an aerial drone
shot of your [ __ ] disgusting body
i know when i've been there it's time to
change it today you're sick of looking
in the mirror and looking so close to
that you can literally only see your not
but in available not even that great to
be honest but a hell of a lot better
than you do now i mean you imagine that
if you die they're gonna just wheel you
out in a wheelbarrow and then dump your
body in a ditch you don't even deserve a
funeral you're disgusting
you're a repulsive mess a massive orb of
flesh
you hate it and you're disgusting you
know there's all the fat activists and
people that tell you to feel good about
yourself but they don't exist in the
real world
they're only on twitter and it only
matters if you're a millionaire like
lizzo who can shake her big ass
but even she's trying to make her ass
smaller because you know what after a
while you say to yourself i'm sick of
having all this ass
you know what i mean unless you like a
big ass and you need a big ass in which
case you can purchase a big ass but they
don't advertise on my show
and if they do i'll change my tune on
that but the point is that eventually
you have to stop it stop the insanity as
susan powder used to say
that spikey heard lesbian look like bart
simpson she did a lot of stuff in the
90s i don't know what happened to her
now
probably died of a methamphetamine
overdose it's not my problem
we're moving on now the diet world is
moving on to paleo and keto and
everything ends with an o and it's
all about getting back to the earth and
nature and natural things
and that's why we're advertising this
cereal because it doesn't have all the
[ __ ] in it
but it feels like it does your marriage
isn't real but it
feels like it is your kids don't love
you but it feels like they do
no one respects you with your job but it
feels like they might
do you see your entire life as pretend
why not add a [ __ ] cereal
to complete the cycle of delusion and
nightmares that you live in
all the [ __ ] time got it
magicspoon.com
tim dillon you need this product you
need manscaped the only
the only other product on the market is
the norelco groom and it's not good
manscape performance package is the
ultimate men's hygiene bundle they got
the weed whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer waterproof
uses 9000 rpm motor powered 360 degree
rotary dual blade system and also
obviously the lawn mower the thing that
that trims your junk
you you got to trim yourself up that's
the way it is
everybody uses it i use it ben use it
everybody i know uses it i
men use it women use it trans men use it
non-binary men
everybody uses manscape and it doesn't
matter who you are what gender you
identify with
it is the best male grooming product on
the market they have everything
you never worry about nicking your dick
or balls when you're using the manscape
thing you can make you can
you can you can shave yourself drunk it
doesn't matter it's
fine you know intoxicated just shave it
down there you got to be
got to be careful because you don't want
to knick-knack your thing
it's bad so manscaped is really
something you actually need they also
gives you two free gifts the manscape
boxers and shed travel bag you'll
receive a replaceable blade every three
months to keep your weed whacking and
lawnmowing
time clean and enjoyable okay it's
really something that is amazing 79
of partners paul admitted that long nose
hair is a major turn off okay manscape
has cornered the market on genital
uh you know shaving but they they're
really looking now to provide solutions
for hair that coming out of other parts
of your body
your nose your ears stuff like that you
know and
and and most people don't like nose hair
i mean this doesn't it's not attractive
to anyone people like body hair maybe
and
certain people are into that certain
people or not nobody's really anyone
knows hair fetish if you meet somebody
that has a nose hair fetish you're into
some weird stuff you know what i mean
very odd you know what i mean are you in
a nose hair
no not at all not armpit hair either
why not it's just not my thing right i
guess it's a
nature versus nurture thing shut up it's
not what it is
what are you even talking about you're
saying words the nature versus nurture
what
explain that i don't know like there's
some there's like genetic imprints where
you might be naturally
predispo predisposed to like wanting
hair on a woman
and you might naturally not or or is it
like you're raised around a woman with a
lot of hair so then you're more
attracted to them
right like which is it is it in your dna
to want to be with a woman i don't know
you brought it up
why why are you going at me with the
question i'm just saying
you asked me why i'm not into it i'm not
sure
it was kind of you just i mean it was
kind of an outburst you just had
i'm just trying to get to the bottom of
what's going on with you right now why
are you feeling
the need to to derail the ad and the
program and
and obstruct
get this the lawnmower 3.0 trimmer the
best trimmer on the market for your
balls butt and body
you shave your [ __ ] do you shave your
[ __ ] with the
the the lawn mower do you actually do i
don't believe you i mean i don't shave
it with a razor but like once hairs get
too long and you just go back there you
refuse to let your wife peg
you that's true yes so what's the point
of having a clean [ __ ] if nobody's
gonna really get in there
well if you have clean hairs it's easier
to wipe
yeah but why don't you let your wife
[ __ ] you
manscape performance package is the
ultimate man's hygiene bundle i just
keep saying it just buy it it you need
it yeah yeah
get 20 off this recall is good get 20
off and freeze i'm probably gonna get in
and out for them tonight that's their
last la meal
ryan lewis lucy yeah and devon and ida
are coming by
i had a minute now sick of spending
money on these lugs
get 20 off of free shipping with the
code teamd
tim d t i md manscape.com that's t-i-m-d
at manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping manscape.com tim d
new year's resolutions folks you got to
stick to them
you got to stick to them what a stupid
economy we have
a new year's resolution based economy
like every every company advertises the
first of the year like are you sick of
being a fat
lazy loaf of [ __ ] are you sick of being
a fat lump of [ __ ] with no more money
how about you get involved
give up carbs and start investing in
bitcoin i'm doing michaela peterson's
podcast by the way she reached out to me
i guess we're going to talk about eating
meat
she's on a carnivore diet and it's cured
all of her diseases which is very nice
i appreciate that she has an autoimmune
it's a weird autoimmune disease do you
know the symptoms of this
what is it the symptoms of it are it's
like inflammation
like you have inflammation all over your
body and then you try to kill your
father
it's folks what i do with this show is i
clear my schedule
i clear my schedule so that now i don't
have to uh do anything
that's obviously a joke what is she in a
lobster costume get her out of here i
hate women oh yeah that was on holiday
i'm kidding
california hospital stressed to the
brink of catastrophe by coronavirus
surge let's play what this woman is
saying okay let's see what's going on
here
let's go to the emergency room nurse
tony catano says her hospital is running
out of oxygen tanks
and space in the morgue our morgue is
full
but it's only a matter of time before
they start breaking out the butcher
trucks
throughout the pandemic she's used her
truck to warn residents of what's to
come she said it's about it's a matter
of time before the butcher trucks come
out yeah
for the bodies i guess is there aren't
there any vans do we have to go right to
butcher truck
do we have to go to the butcher it
sounds like a threat she's like it's
only a matter of time before the butcher
trucks come out
then it's the fire pits after the fire
pits what
well i mean listen i i think it's bad
what's going on in l.a now i feel
[ __ ] horrible about this i don't want
i don't want anybody getting sick and i
don't want these hospitals overloaded my
question is why
why we didn't prepare for a second wave
and i've talked about it at nauseam and
maybe there's only so much
preparation you could do but we we
there's got to be more but there should
have been field hospitals and tents and
like
there there should have been increased
icu capacity hiring more nurses i don't
know
um but the whole thing's amassed and i
feel bad about it let's watch a little
bit more of this i mean
you know it's it's [ __ ] hairy
different trend of covid cases continues
10 hours later yes there's still just as
many ambulances
they don't they don't stop coming
they'll stop coming
cases in the state have surged in spite
of strict covid 19 protocols
including a stay-at-home order while
california's governor gavin newsom
pushed for a lockdown in parts of the
state
shutting down theme parks limiting
dining at restaurants
and shuttering movie theaters to flatten
the curve meantime in florida
a state that's been wide open for months
things are still faring better
rate of new covet cases why public
health experts say
los angeles was uniquely susceptible to
an infectious disease outbreak
what los angeles county i think is home
to some of the most
overcrowded housing setups in the
country
and because of that you're seeing a lot
of
um well get your own place of the virus
shut her up get your own spot
what the [ __ ] the problem get your own
[ __ ] dude i see some of these people
living together they're like 80.
just like some 80 year old old woman
living with a bunch of people i'm like
yo [ __ ] get your own [ __ ] spot
what are you 80 you're still living with
people
[ __ ] do something get a studio
apartment how gross
get your own [ __ ] spot this [ __ ] is
right
she's like there's just too many people
living together it's time to spread your
wings
get out there live your life
god it's not hard
what's the average cause of a house in
california let's see
in l.a average purchased home
buy a [ __ ] home dummy
650 grand is the medium price and by the
way i don't know where the [ __ ] you get
that this is all fake
but you know what's the problem
i think they're counting condos in that
there's no way so what so just get your
own spot
it's 6.50 650k
i don't understand the problem
get a new investment guy is that the
problem probably
a lot of these people in la dying of
covert right now because they live in
crowded spaces
need to get a new investment team stop
i don't get it
whatever i just this is this is what ben
shapiro thinks
and turning point usa they're like
they're like just get a new just like
what's going on
are you not like invested are you not in
the market
in a healthy way
so this is very sad there's a lot of
people in la they're taking the bullet
they're dying of coronavirus they're
dying in the hospitals and now
apparently they're going to bring
butcher trucks for the bodies because
there's no more mobile morgues or
something
dude it's very [ __ ] uh what's the
word ghoulish it's very ghoulish and sad
and i don't know what to do i i don't
know what to do i think it's still a
little nutty people can't sit outside on
a patio and have a salad
but they can stand arm to arm in costco
and buy a big jar of icing to eat with
their family
i don't understand it it's a sloppy
enforcement it's uneven it's selectively
enforced it's bad for everybody it's bad
for the economy
it's probably not bad for it's probably
not good for people's health
i don't know the solution there's a lot
of overcrowded housing in l.a there's a
lot of people that live together in la
most of them are tick-tocking
you walk into these houses these large
mexican populations
it's like get a job none of these
mexicans work
they're all tick-tocking trying to be
famous that's the problem with l.a
you go to these densely populated
mexican-american communities
and it's like oh my god they're never
working they're always just tick-tocking
it's crazy because that's what they're
talking about by the way when they say
densely populated communities talking
about mexicans they're not talking about
like
you know the 800 000 people in the
hollywood hills right now
uh shaking their ass on camera every
[ __ ] day
by the way every day there's evidence of
just 19
people right
so many of you didn't catch that then
you don't catch the levels of arnie on
the show it's not my fault i'm just
going to hold the mic like this
what if i just broadcast it like this
what if i did that what if my whole
thing was this
[Laughter]
and i was like do you not do not like it
alex jones went little nuts on the
livestream that could not have gone on
youtube he would have lost our channel
no no no no he wanted like a 45 minute
anti
mercs rant and i just don't think
we were waiting for that place that
company we used rush ticks to shut us
down
yeah i thought we were waiting for them
to go hey man we we've aired a lot of
stuff but
yeah this is too much
calling the vaccine jellyfish it's an
mrna vaccine it's jellyfish
they're putting jellyfish inside
okay and then he left our show and got
in a tank to go yell at the mayor of
austin
who lives in the w hotel that's
literally true literally he left our
show got an attack tina 40 was on the
show
you know the woman who's always like
[ __ ] cuomo you call me
[ __ ] tina 40 we found this out
during the live stream
almost died of coronavirus in the
hospital literally almost died and now
is going to be leading flash mobs of
anti-massacres to run into grocery
stores without masks and just
scare people
question why does the country
deserve to endure
think about it think about that
if we did make it wouldn't it be a weird
aberration
like if this country figured out a way
to limp into the next century somehow
wouldn't that be odd i'm not saying i'm
not for it
i live here but with the behavior of
people
isn't it we do have a little bit of a
death wish
i'm not saying you should wear a mask
all the goddamn time but to be like hey
i'm going to lead flash mobs
in the starbucks that doesn't seem like
a good idea
it seems and she almost died of the
coven she doesn't care
hospital too weak she said yeah she's a
real warrior
americans just want to fight for
something they don't even care what it
is
they don't even care what they're
fighting for it's just it's time to
fight
god bless her she came on the show we
respect her
you know i appreciate it but you know it
seems strange
if somebody spent two weeks in the
hospital coronavirus i don't think their
next thing would be i'm going to
lead flash mobs of anti-massacres to run
around cvs
that's an odd reaction to have no also
what does that prove
and whose mind does that change you
think anyone's like well i took over
seriously until i saw 100 people running
around
this grocery store now i realize the era
of my ways
you know just open up
ocean prime outside so i can get the
truffle deviled egg and i'll be fine
everybody's interested personal open up
ocean prime on the patio i want truffle
deviled egg
which is not being offered as part of
the takeout menu one of the biggest
problems people are having now
is the takeout menus and the uh in in
restaurant dining menus
are very different and this is a big
source of consternation to a lot of
people including myself who are like
what's going on here i want the thing
that i get
here and they're like well we don't do
that anymore and i'm like well we're
gonna yeah
we're gonna you know why because the
butcher trucks are coming
and they're taking everyone out and
butchering us up and they're gonna sell
us from meat on the street
before that i would like the deviled egg
is there a way that we can
do that please because we're clearly all
living at the end of something
and i'd like a little before the end
we had a big problem with airbnb and
i've been a big proponent of airbnb and
airbnb is a billion dollar business
and it's valued at how much do you mean
they just had a ipo right
airbnb is uh this massive
uh i mean it is just
it's 68 dollars a share i mean
it's it's 33 billion valuation as of
november 30th for airbnb
okay now it's targeting that is december
7th 42 billion
variation for airbnb and we had a
problem with airbnb
we had a real issue with airbnb i have
done
nothing but be respectful to the people
to the homes that i rent i've done
nothing
you understand i do not get bad reviews
on airbnb because i treat
people with respect now
let's describe let's describe some of
the issues
number one i went i was told i was going
to a luxury compound in joshua tree
luxury
means something very specific to me okay
it doesn't mean
necessarily stylized high concept and
artistic it means luxury it means
fluffy couches and nice carpets luxury i
feel
luxurious you understand
um we went to a nice
thing in joshua tree which is the place
where all people in the tech industry go
to take mushrooms and
people that work for ice go and have you
know to take dmt and
figure out how to build stronger cages
to put kids in you know it's great it's
for people having revelations
so we go to joshua tree which is really
just it's a litter box for drug addicts
let's be honest
it's a litter box for drug addicts and i
know that a lot of people like it but
that's what it is and that's who you are
so we go to this litter box for drug
addicts and they you know they've stuck
a little house on the edge of the
cliff and we can all go see the desert
and you know take a bunch of drugs and
see satan or whatever
and um we get into the house the house
the furniture in the house is like it's
all it's all
of course these are two white women i
believe they're lesbians i don't want to
i say that they're lesbians i don't know
but their names are stupid like one of
them's name's mila
it's like it's a stupid name you're a
ridiculous person okay
you accuse me of breaking a cactus how
do you even do that you goofy [ __ ] shut
the [ __ ] up
okay you slob so i walk into your
[ __ ] house which you can't even sit
on the [ __ ] front i got fat people
here
they're 400 pounds how are they gonna
sit on your cowhide chair
that's a little thin thing of [ __ ]
leather what are we supposed to do
this guy's 900 pounds what are we gonna
do here okay
every piece of furniture can't sodomize
the guest
you have to have some [ __ ] chair that
works like an actual [ __ ] chair
throw a beanbag in there okay not
everybody's a 90-foot
90-pound lesbian on ayahuasca that can
perch on a [ __ ] bird cage
for the whole night okay you freaks
listen the [ __ ] up
talking to you people are gonna rent
your house that are actual people that
need
actual furniture to actually sit not
everything's a [ __ ] trip to
hyperspace
there's actual 3d reality that some of
us have to [ __ ] live in
so we went there
and i was not thrilled with the decor
and i
i told you that it was very uh white and
you know these white
[ __ ] they just steal native american
culture and i'm not even a culturally
appropriation guy but they just steal
this [ __ ] culture
they put these weird little uh buffalo
head skulls everywhere and
you know lavender oil and what am i
gonna do lube my ass with it what are
you
what is this so we go in
it's all white the fireplace doesn't
work of course because the insurance
company won't insure them
everything's freezing the hot tub is
freezing
unhappy right the [ __ ] lock box we
gotta [ __ ] attack it to get the key
out
um so we're there in the house and
we do nothing to the furniture we
literally don't damage any of the
furniture they have these kitchen stools
that are concrete slabs
we work so hard for the shut up
get a job they're are concrete slab
kitchen chairs high top kitchen chairs
okay
that are like art pieces these are not
chairs right and they have little stools
that are made out of what what was that
like
hollowed out so like marble or the
marble petrified wood
petrified wood or i don't know what it
was
it's a little stool that you're supposed
to sit it's a tiny little table
where your ass can't even fit on this
small little thing of wood that you have
to sit on
and eat i don't even know what right
so they just want you doing drugs do you
walk in there's a big mortar and a
pestle there
and they're like just crush it up just
crush it up and do it
get it into the blood sugar and that's
fine listen i got it i got janja
i tagged the shrimps but some people
want to have a nice
meal there we treated that house that
could have never been treated
with wholesome american food
we went to vons in the desert and we got
burgers and bushes baked beans and we
cooked
baked beans and yes beans explode when
they're hot yeah
whose fault is that i didn't come up
with the idea for the bean
they explode without and then we wanted
uh gordon's fish we got the gorton's
fish which is very nice
the breaded pre-breaded gourds fish and
some tartar sauce
so we so baked beans gordon's fish with
tartar sauce cheeseburgers and then
seven pints of ice cream so we could try
yeah
just have a little ice cream testing and
we left a few dishes
in the sink in the sink a pot of
exploded beans
an extra tartar sauce i didn't even use
that i said you can use
um some ice cream i mean the smell of
the house was
fish and bean but that's not my fault
you couldn't have a cleaning because
she's like the cleaning crew complained
what what is it my fat maid over there
probably complaining
but it's like well why are they
complaining they're supposed to be
cleaning their job is to clean
okay so this [ __ ] then texts me she
goes our cleaning crew had a heart
attack lol so i'm like okay
and then she goes but please give us a
good review should we stay on airbnb so
here's the deal with airbnb we review
each other we don't know what we've said
if you're gonna come reach out to me and
ask me for a good review and acknowledge
that the cleaning crew's like oh we
gotta wash some dishes
i'm like okay they're not mad we didn't
do anything there's some dishes in the
sink but it is what it is i paid a 400
cleaning fee you stupid [ __ ] jonah and
mila
you [ __ ] pigs i'll burn your [ __ ]
house down
by the way anyway i texted them that i
texted them i was gonna burn their house
down
and i sent them a gif of the simpsons
house burning i'm like i know where your
house is they're like are you
threatening me i'm like let's just see
what happens
i'm like stay safe out there you stupid
desert dykes
i will have god hates [ __ ] church
outside of your [ __ ] house every
[ __ ] day
i will call uh who is the people in
there who are the names westboro baptist
yeah westborough and who are the names
uh
fred phelps the phelps family i'll get
the whole fels family not the [ __ ] that
went on rogue and the rest of them that
stayed true
i will get them out there every [ __ ]
night to [ __ ] yell at the people
renting your stupid drug den
anyway so i responded to her by saying
no one broke anything your house sucks
because she said i was a bad guest and
then and then people are like did this
really happen
it can't really happen i said the fu the
furniture is unusable you're not artists
your home is wildly overpriced true
you begged me for a good rating and then
trashed me the cleaning crew complained
about cleaning who's your cleaning crew
there was some dishes that is all i
don't really care about your reviews i
don't rent out my home to strangers like
an animal good luck with everything in
the future
the place is a dump and it looks like it
was furnished by drug addicts
which i imagine you are please get the
help you need if you want me to take you
to an a.a meeting or an n a meeting i
will go to ikea
get some actual furniture which
hopefully you can afford not everything
has to be an art piece
and feel free to use the tartar sauce i
left behind later
pig and that's what i wrote to them on
airbnb and no response
and then i and then i sent a few that
could have been considered
quasi-threatening messages but they were
not threats they were an art piece
like your furniture they're not meant to
be sat on or taken literally i was doing
an art
piece you see it was all a metaphor
and an anger it angered me because she
[ __ ] on me publicly on airbnb which
anyone can see
truly and now i look like the bad guy
i look like the bad guy
jonah and mila [ __ ] you
we didn't do anything dishes were in the
sink
the hot tub wasn't hot you already paid
400 for a clean if we're not supposed to
eat the gorton's fish
why would they sell it at the
supermarket
i'm not getting fresh fish i trust the
gordon's fishermen
and it's a lovely if you've ever had a
gorton's they're lovely very good
and then the mccormick tartar sauce goes
very well with it it pairs very well
i'm sorry i wasn't doing speed balls in
your bathroom
like the rest of your guests
you [ __ ] pigs you've done nothing
but create a [ __ ] satanic vortex for
people to sin
and i didn't take part in it i made
bowls of baked beans
i'll i will not toler i will not
tolerate
being disparaged publicly like that
and this good man does he he did nothing
wrong
he slept in a room where the sun
hit him directly in the face as soon as
it came up because there were no [ __ ]
curtains yeah
because curtains are too basic for these
[ __ ]
hoes and i hope they hear this by the
way i hope someone in your garbage life
shows you this podcast you are nothing
do you understand me
you clowns look at your airbnb picture
you're
you pose with your [ __ ] dogs you're
clowns
you're not interesting and you were not
an artist you are failures and you were
drug addicts
and i'm telling you right now if you had
any clue the holy hell that was about to
rain down on you
you would [ __ ] run you would have you
would run out into the desert and
sacrifice yourself
because every day i swear to christ
every [ __ ] day i wake up and i think
about how to destroy you and that
[ __ ]
and i'll figure it out and see this is
what i mean about the cops can't call me
out on this because it's my right
to kind of vent these frustrations and i
can't because they can't knock on my
door and say hey did you say you're
gonna kill these
two dykes and joshua tree i can't this
is what i mean do you see in real time
i'm proving my point from the beginning
of the show that's why the show is
entertaining
and it's informative because the reality
is we're all having these thoughts all
the time
because what i really want to do is gas
these two in their house and watch them
just
i want to watch them [ __ ] climb over
their shitty art house furniture and get
to the [ __ ] door and just
just they can't get any breath and then
fall and then just walk in and i want to
piss on their corpses but i'm not going
to do that
i'm not going to do that
i'm just going to talk about it do you
understand the difference
and if putting on a hispanic accent made
me feel a little better
if being a little exotic made me feel
better if pretending to be an eastern
european
or pretending to be a russian or
pretending to be asian if that made me
feel a little better if it got me
through my day
if it decreased the chances and i was
going to go back and burn this [ __ ]
[ __ ] down in the middle of joshua
tree
because they've wronged me if that made
me feel a little better than what the
[ __ ] wrong with that what is the
problem
with that i'm not putting pig heads on
pelosi's door i just want to go hey come
and see this
cucumber i don't know how to talk in the
english i don't know how to do it
so what's the [ __ ] problem out there
pick and choose your battles do you
understand
and i hope and this show's a big show i
hope to god
someone shows it to these people and i
will get in a high-profile war with both
of you ladies
okay cause i'm a [ __ ] too okay
you can't do that straight white man
[ __ ] on me okay
i will suck a [ __ ] in your house and
then burn it down i don't know what
that'll prove
it sounded more progressive as i was
saying it it actually sounded quite
hateful as i was saying it as well
my point is this stop there's nothing
worse than lesbians who think they're
artists
you're not just build a [ __ ] shed you
apes
katie herzog's not trying to be an
artist she's [ __ ] sitting in her
backyard with her dumb dog
and and [ __ ] trying to figure out why
her neighbor identifies as a fruit loop
by the way i've been having a
conversation with a 17 year old
dude who's on the track team in in where
i live
thinking he's katie herzog for the last
[ __ ] month he goes dude what's your
problem why do you keep asking me about
trans issues i said aren't you katie
herzog
he goes no i'm a 17 year old track star
i said oh well then i'll move on
i just got a message from mikayla
peterson she's like we're booked off
i was on rogan for one of the biggest
episodes the person who wrote this ad
copy said his biggest episode ever
that's untrue it was one of the biggest
one the companies that advertise in the
show are either a super great product
that i love
or have a gang of money and usually both
to be working with me
and this one in particular is a fan of
my comedy which means he is like you i
mean this guy
great guy fan of my comedy veteran
respect him i mean
horrible writer but i do i'm wearing the
underwear right now
actually and it's great underwear um
it's great as a bathing suit
it's great to say and i wasn't in my
underwear for the entire episode we're
just doing ads now
but the reality is
this guy i have a lot of respect for him
um
he started a company that's really
successful sheath underwear is great we
all wear it it's really
cool um it has a little pouch you can
put your dick in
which is very important um because your
balls and your dick it keeps them all
separate so you don't sweat especially
in the heat it's very important in the
heat
um they paid me to promote them which we
all know
but i actually use the product you know
what i mean
um and i respect it do you know who this
guy
this is the guy who this the guy who
owns his company
and and which is pretty cool i didn't
know about this
remember when moammar gaddafi was
sodomized to death
this is the guy who did that
they have a dual pouch separate
compartments
for maximum support and performance mode
dial spandex fabric blend is
is cool to the touch it provides
absorption designer waistband
eye-catching waistbands offered in
different themes and color schemes for
added style multi-directional stretching
fabric sculpts
precisely it's as comfortable as you can
get right so comfortable it's really and
it doesn't bother me do i have very
sensitive skin
i look horrible today obviously i've
spent a week just destroying myself but
uh i have very sensitive skin and it
actually ah
it doesn't ever i'm never bothered by it
right
why won't you let your wife [ __ ] you in
the ass
has she ever expressed a desire to no
never
do you know people that do that like of
course people that are evolved
i don't understand she's never expressed
the desire to just put on a fake dildo
and ram you in the ass no
sheath underwear dot com use code tim30
save 30
is that true just till christmas i think
the sale is still going
that's the copy they sent but use tim30
you save
30 on the underwear i'm telling you
right now it's a great way to support
the show and i'll be very honest with
you it's the most
comfortable underwear i've ever used and
it is something that's pretty cool
and the guy who started this company
is a veteran who served our country
you know what i mean and um so to me
it's like that
that is a very he was the guy who threw
bin laden's body in the water
you know so i thought that was that's a
pretty cool thing to do to like have
that story
you know what i mean it's true he was um
you know
they he was going to try to get a job at
one of those merced groups like
blackwater but they said he was too
violent
so he had to start an underwear company
but he's doing a great job
i really appreciate this guy because he
lets me say whatever i want on these ads
which i like
and the underwear is good the product's
good i mean i i mean you know
i i don't i've never nobody's ever had a
problem with sheath underwear nobody's
ever had a problem with sheath underwear
you know what about one time what about
one time if she said
i just want to stick something up but as
far as it can go you would still say
no i'm very uncomfortable with that
i don't think i could do that because it
would hurt you yeah that sounds painful
it's very painful but do you know what
else is painful
anything worth it
sheath underwear dot com
use code tim30
very few ads you can break out into that
buy this if nothing else buy this
because this guy is the best sense of
humor of any company advertising on the
show
this guy literally is the biggest comedy
fan that advertises on the show
he advertises on every all of your
favorite comedy podcasts
he's one of the companies that allows us
to make a living do whatever we want say
whatever we want and have fun
and if you're a fan of this show you
should be a fan of that
that's dead serious about that like 100
and he also shot jfk he's the guy who
shot jfk in that
sheath underwear.com i want to do lex
friedman show i like lex friedman a lot
there's a few shows i want to do i know
i'm trying to put together a few shows i
wanted you know marin's never had me on
but i guess that's just part of the
thing now
that's okay i don't care it seems he
only has people on if they're promoting
something like a
show or a book okay well there's been
i've had two specials and
multiple things to promote he probably
doesn't like me probably that's fine
i'll live i actually want to get out of
comment like i really don't care about
comedy anymore
i like i love it and it's my lifeblood
but it's also destroying me
and i want to do this show and i will be
out live and stuff and i will be doing
comedy
because i don't have a choice i have to
do it because it's the only way that i
don't go back to joshua tree with a
[ __ ]
bow and arrow but i uh
but uh you know i just have it's gotten
slicks to the point where it's kind of
like
i don't even care anymore would you want
to open a restaurant
we're gonna do a lot of cool live [ __ ]
when [ __ ] opens up we're gonna take over
a restaurant for 48 hours we're gonna do
this we're gonna do a pop-up restaurant
just to [ __ ] around do a menu all that
[ __ ] we might do a food truck
i just want to [ __ ] do [ __ ] to not be
bored i can't be in some comedy club
forever
i need to do crazy live [ __ ] we're
playing around with the idea of doing
like this is year
down the line or whatever a fake
business convention you go to this hotel
we get all these crazy
comics to do [ __ ] about fake business
you know sexual harassment training with
mark norman
just funny [ __ ] you know like a two-day
[ __ ]
crazy type of event experience i want to
do these weird experiences i did it
in new york where i rented this tour bus
we went all over new york city doing
same crazy chat
and i think that's what i want to start
focusing on like obviously i love
standup i'm always going to do it it's
it's it's
a you know it's a gym you work out this
is what you
you do that's how you stay funny but
like i want to create these crazy
experiences where people are like that
[ __ ] was [ __ ] wild
you know whether it's like doing a
pop-up restaurant where people could
come and have this restaurant experience
it's also a comedy experience
or they could come and do this [ __ ]
crazy cell seminar where we put real
motivational speakers with fake ones you
don't know who's who and everybody's
just [ __ ]
crazy here's another thing i want to do
which i think would be really funny i
want to do a show on joshua trey
like do a comedy show on joshua tree
with like 100 people
and then lead them to this [ __ ]
airbnb where we burn it down
and we we take both of the women who own
it out of their house
and we rip pieces of their skin off one
by one
we de-skin them outside of their home
uh and then spread them with honey and
then let african bees eat them because
that is a
that's a thing in africa where like
that's like a punishment in africa if
you're caught like i don't know trying
to steal someone's bitcoin
something i don't know i vent my anger
here it's important because
listen and here's the reality if
anyone's watching this from the fbi
or one of i love those women i love
those i love
people that take risks to make beautiful
art everything i have said
is comedy i love
those women i love them and i respect
them and i
and i and i'm sorry that we had a
difference of opinion as relating to
business
but i am hoping that in the future
i'm hoping in the future that we can
come together they're welcome to come on
the show
and you're welcome to come on my i'm
kidding about
skinning you you're welcome to come on
the show
because we didn't do anything wrong
right
i don't think so we have the truth with
us and the people that have the truth
are close to the light of the lord okay
ladies
um so when i have the truth with me
i proceed with confidence so you are
more than welcome to come on my show to
zoom in or skype in
and tell me what you think i did
because i did nothing i did nothing but
infuse your
home with love
and laughter and light and i was [ __ ] on
you took a big [ __ ] on me publicly on
airbnb which is
[ __ ] up it's [ __ ] up
what you ladies did and i hope you live
with that i hope you live with that
every day of your life
and i know you're watching this right
now i know you two are watching this
right now right
and you're gonna call your friend who's
a lawyer he ain't that ain't that
successful is he
and you're gonna call him and you're
gonna say is can we do anything about
you can't
you can't i've got lawyers too piglet
and i'm telling you right now i'm
telling you i want you to look at my
face and when you look at my eyes do you
are you both sitting on the couch with
you
with your dogs in your loveless
childless home i want you to look at me
i will never let up
for the rest of my life you were the one
bad airbnb review i have i will never
ever ever ever ever ever let up
and it won't be just a p it won't be
just pig's blood in the driveway
okay it won't be just some antifa
scribbling with
a spray cam okay when i decide
when i pounce
it'll be hiroshima it'll be nagasaki
ladies i'm kidding come on the show come
on the show literally
literally come on the show because i am
kidding i don't care anymore i'm not
gonna blow up your house or kill you
it's
you both could probably kill me you're
you're you're you're you're you know
i don't know come on the show we're just
having fun here
this is what i mean i'm illustrating how
you gotta invent you gotta you gotta let
loose because we don't care anymore i
really don't care it doesn't matter
i'll still get airbnbs uh but i just i
want you to come on
i want you to come on the show i want
you to come on the show i'm gonna blow
up your car
i'm gonna blow up one of your cars i
that but that's it
but i'm gonna blow up one of your cars
one of you is
gonna get thrown out of a car with
third-degree barns
only one only one of you
and then you're probably gonna get out
of the airbnb business aren't you
you look at your wife with a crusty face
and you go
man man we should have just tolerated
that smell of good gorton's fish
but i'm kidding hey dummy not gonna blow
up your car i don't even know how to do
that i don't even know how to do it
just come on the show and and
and you can you can yell at me get my
instagram down please
leave this up the whole time are you
paying attention
i didn't put it on screen okay all right
he's very vicious vicious he's very
vicious
and he always has a plan and he never
really is out in the open with his
thoughts and feelings
and he buries them very deeply and then
he lets them out months later and you
know you do
you know you let them out months later
there's deep-seated anger and rage you
have towards me
and you have to work that out i'm not
the one with the anger problem here you
are
because i get all my anger out on the
show but you sit and stew with it
and you and that woman uh sit there and
you
and you just and you just sit there and
stir your little pot of hell
you stir your little pot of hell you
know and you try to and you try to
you try to you know and i i watch you
closely as i watch her
okay so just know that you're being
watched
do you understand that
i'm going to
i'm going to i like to rent i'd like
someone to rent this airbnb
under their name and have me go
and then take photos in it and then put
them on my social media and be like
can't keep me up [ __ ]
that's kind of funny right that's like a
happy medium i'm not hurting them or
blowing their house up but it's just
funny
and i'm like in the airbnb so if you
live in california and you want to rent
an airbnb and just throw a straight up
party
just a covert party you have to be an
essential worker to
rent right now so as long as they're
essential not in their kit not in the
joshua tree county oh really
correct interesting uh they told me that
because i tried to wrap them out too
which i never do but i'm like i'm
reporting you guys i said i literally
text him i'm like i work for gavin
newsom
i'm gonna get you again instead of
laughing you're like not in our county
i'm like
lesbian no sense of humor very very
telling sign
um when i do the wrong thing i don't
like
i'm not getting my palm springs deposit
back cause duncan ate the couch
that's fine the bottom the under the
black
and i paid for pool heat i wanted to
heat the pool but
my point is that i don't want to belabor
the point we're going to get out of here
in a minute and we do appreciate
everybody who
enjoyed the live stream and it was a lot
of fun and it's up on patreon now
whatever
um but at the end of the day i feel like
we must always fight for what is right
and true and just
truly you know what i mean that's why i
have to watch you
because i want you to be always with the
purest of intentions
and sometimes and even you would you
would you would
you have inside of you a little cauldron
of of rage
just a tiny bit and you don't get your
feelings out
because sometimes i you then come back
to me three months later with something
that's true you're not you're not saying
that's true no it's true i'm bad at
being honest or expressing myself
and i have a little bit of anger and
that's why i vape constantly it just
keeps it all down and you're angry at me
sometimes i've been angry at you
sometimes you've been angry at me yeah
at me you've been angry angry with
with you is that you've been angry with
me yeah
why would you be angry with me we we've
had
i mean we've known each other a long
time now we've worked closely together
sometimes there's fights you know
but you think you're right i get upset
you get upset because you're wrong
sometimes yeah
sometimes i know you're right and it
upsets me and then sometimes i've been
wrong
interesting but you apologize later
perhaps
we just i i feel like we must start the
year on a good foot
yes i can't have you and your wife
trying to kill me all the time
do you understand that
you know
see he's laughing because he knows it's
true you're laughing because you know
it's true
that we want to kill you the depths of
hatred that that woman has for me
are it's like the mariana trench it's
the deepest part of the ocean
and and all you try to do is
is you know mitigate that to the degree
that you can
that's okay i i i am
i am always with god with love and light
and truth and justice
you and her have turned from the church
i have not
that's the difference between us wow
does it make sense now yeah we've turned
our backs on god and
you're an example of what it's like to
bathe in christ's light
that is exactly right yes i can't even
yell at you because you said that so
perfectly do you understand many people
they'll never understand that no no no
so even though we have our our struggles
our trials and tribulations
we come out on the other end because i
think you understand that i
am your way to the light of the lord i
open the gates up for you
and for her to come in why shut the
gates
hear that milan can uh my name is mila
my name is mila i work so hard on my
airbnb
i'm mila how'd you work hard stealing
the culture of native americans you
genocidal [ __ ]
how'd you work hard again giving a
family a indian some smallpox blankets
and then taking their [ __ ] art
and adorning that shed in joshua trees
so that white pigs can go there and
drink ergot wine how'd you work hard
again
how'd you work hard again
the only part of the airbnb i didn't
check before we left was rey's backhouse
so i didn't check that did you check
that interesting no
so we may owe these two women an apology
god only knows that rey did in there
i gotta be honest with you we may owe
these two ladies in the
jonah and mila hey i'm sorry
good night